Oh London come on six locks want anybody
want to come up here that's it yeah
every once a lady let jeans go yes sir
hi
god bless the Republic
[Applause]
okay here we are again day 2 of
preparing a textbook Jeff Davis shell
we're talking with dr. Joel Wallach who
is has a video here it's called dead
doctors don't lie and some interesting
that acclaims on the video I wanted to
mention that the average two died and
you're sitting here cemetery has died
the average age of medical doctors in
1993 was fifty seven point six years
maybe I'll let you in addition okay
think we don't get into we get into that
okay that's fine I think this thing that
makes my background will the unique Jeff
is that I'm a veterinarian as well as a
physician and growing up on a farm in
Missouri I recognize we're going a lot
of trouble for our calves giving them
vitamins and minerals and trace minerals
their pellets and as a family beat it
out of the same field to eat the same
corn soy beans and carrots and whatnot
and we didn't get ourselves the same
vitamins and minerals and trace metals
when I'd ask my dad I say hey cops how
come you get all the calves the vitamins
and minerals of tracing their own we eat
out of the same fields and they're only
around for nine months and we want to
live to be a hundred you don't get the
same vitamins and minerals and trace
minerals and you'd say shut up boy farm
fresh food fresh air free exercise don't
has complicated questions but when I got
into vet school I recognized that the
reason why we give animals vitamins and
minerals and trace metals it's because
we don't have insurance for them and if
we were to use a human health care type
of system for animals it'd be sticker
shock for your hamburger cost two
hundred seventy dollars a pound and I
started looking into the health
questions even
medical school myself and so the
criteria the question I had to ask
myself was well who knows the most about
health it should be doctors so I started
looking at doctors health and their
longevity it was very disappointing
the average American was to be seventy
five point five and no matter whose
statistics you look at the worst is 58
the best of 70
there's no statistic that shows that
doctors live as long as the average
American so I started investigating why
and the biggest reason the doctors too
high other than fast cars and airplanes
and drugs is that they don't supplement
with vitamins and minerals and trace
minerals even the average American will
take vitamin C or vitamin E eighty five
percent to take tums for calcium
something doctors don't do that as a
group but they're great control group
opposed as a group they do not take
supplements and as a result they don't
live as long as the average American and
so that's the premise of that tape you
don't want to listen to doctors when it
comes to health and longevity if you
have a broken bone they're great for
putting pins in as far as giving you
advice on nutrition and health
they just don't have any training you
don't get 30 seconds of clinical
nutrition in medical school I went on to
become a physician that practice at
Portland Oregon for 12 years as a family
practitioner I used everything I'd
learned in veterinary nutrition of my
human patients and it works just as well
in people as a dozen animals and I have
a book out which we didn't bring but
it's the bestseller it's called let's
play doctor
it teaches people how to use vitamins
and minerals and trace minerals to treat
and reverse over 400 diseases and the
most famous formula those 400 formulas
they call the doctor wall aches big
arthritis from and not that there's any
pigs in it but because it was designed
to prevent cure arthritis and pigs works
just like a charm in human beings and
it's very simple it's like a little cake
recipe make it home it's five ounces of
calcium enriched Minute Maid orange
juice as a half ounce or six to twelve
capsules over the gelatin of the
chondroitin sulfate for rebuilding
cartilage and bone and then one ounce of
a liquid colloidal minerals ma which is
derived from the plant material dr.
Wallach spurgeon earth colloidal
minerals name 77 minerals of 60 of which
are known to be essential this is
derived from plants as opposed to
rounded rocks which was 98 percent
available to you and then one ounce of a
liquid multiple known as dr. Lodge birch
and Earth ultimate contains 112
nutrients and you mix these four basic
ingredients together against seven and a
half ounces of mix which you want to
take from breakfast people
since winter time Nessun almost
alcoholics bigger threats from actually
rebuild your cartilage and bones their
joints and these the hands shoulders
hips even if you're 70 80 I know you're
a young man you know thinking think your
global about but as you get older it
started falling apart you need this
stuff so there's how long have you been
down in this town since 1958 1958 and of
course have a tape out this old twenty
two million tapes called
dead doctors don't lie it's an audio
cassette tape the video hasn't quite
sold F&E but twenty two million in the
audio cassettes that doctors don't lie
and it's just I guess the most listened
to nutritional lecture history of the
world
what are you what's your basic claim
that that well I'm saying he'd looking
at your video you you you're not
claiming of course that or Rockwell what
do you claim it as she lost their gross
that I'd be any type of cancer well
basically what I'm saying Jeff is that
you cannot get everything you need from
your for food ruse that sentence has
probably killed more Americans than all
the foreign enemies put together you
cannot get everything you need
words grains vegetables fruits and nuts
can take carbon dioxide out of the air
and manufacture flanimals vitamin C B
vitamins folic acid vitamin E because
their carbon chains plants takes the
carbon dioxide out of the air it is the
sun's energy photosynthesis and
manufacturer vitamins the plants cannot
manufacture amenities we need 90
essential nutrients 60 of the ninety or
minerals two thirds or minerals and
we're assuming that we can get
everything we need from our four food
groups because the medical profession
has taught public that well minerals
never ever even in the best of times in
the good old days occurred in a uniform
blanket around the trusty Earth
Merrill's always occurred in veins
the ice-cream and it's worse than a
throw of the dice you're more likely to
win a million dollars every day for 30
days in a row in Vegas from the
one-armed bandits than you are to get
here 60 essential minerals every day by
eating your floor who knows it's just
not going to happen
osteoporosis is a deficiency of calcium
and magnesium and sulfur and other
minerals degenerative arthritis wear and
tear arthritis osteoarthritis is just
costea Prosis to the joint ends of bones
diabetes is a deficiency of things like
chromium and vanadium - trace minerals
85% of all diabetics are the fish in the
chromium and vanadium you can actually
get people off of insulin in about two
or three months by supplementing with
the chloride a farmer from vanadium high
blood pressures due to a calcium
deficiency not by eating too much salt
so you can actually reduce your risk of
cancer up to 85% by just taking in 250
to 500 micrograms to the trace mineral
selenium and
I'll tell you this I say well when you
get cancer with you too cute there well
let me let me just answer for sure a
weird question that what ready is where
do you do you have any particular theory
or research or best guess as to where
all this misinformation where it began
you brought well it's very simple Jeff
during the turn of the century during
the 1890s and 1910 the family physician
was kind of an extended member of the
family he'd stay overnight at your house
over the baby chocolate and this guy was
really interested in helping people he
wasn't there to make money if you
couldn't pay he would take a side of
beef four dozen eggs or meal after
church later might be payment after the
Second World War when doctors were
elevated by the discovery of penicillin
sulfa drugs and great surgical
techniques because of the trauma they
had to fix during war they were elevated
to more than just an extended family
member to somebody on a pedestal and at
that time doctors stopped taking eggs
and science beef and after church
dinners his payment they started
demanding that you pay otherwise they'd
send you the bill collector and it was
after the Second World War when doctors
didn't need people anymore
they had penicillin sulfa drugs with
prednisone and so they felt that
everybody needed them more was reality
and this is where the misinformation at
that point
it all occurred right around the second
let me just briefly here if you've done
any research like if it's an oxidant
they have been well sure oxygen therapy
is a food grade hydrogen peroxide
hyperbaric oxygen spent a lot of time
dealing with these certainly oxygen can
increase the rate of healing of anything
athletic the team's know that they have
about oxygen therapy and hyperbaric
chambers for their athletes instead of
being out for six to eight weeks when
they get a joint injury as two to three
weeks they use hyperbaric oxygen so
there's just no doubt about it
you have a stroke a lot of people are
debilitated 50% 75% after stroke not
because all the cells and their brain
are dead but because they're in a coma
they don't have enough oxygen to
function properly you put these people
with a stroke into a hyperbaric oxygen
chamber in 30 to 40 days 60 days they
can regain 75 to 90 and maybe interpret
senator function back because the cells
were never dead they were just a private
oxygen what about apple cider vinegar
sure habit idol I have the cider videos
and one of the old Britain daddies of
the home remedies that can certainly
help the digestion they had certain
digestive herbs with it like gentians
and the English bitters can enhance
digestion prevent belching burping and
bloating heartburn
help you absorb minerals better I
acidifying your stomach doctor well like
I want to thank you for being on Jeff
Davis mentioned too if you want do what
this give like that closing statement
are you sure bit about what what what
you're all about
okay well basically we have these
colloidal minerals we have educational
materials like the tapes we have a
fertilizer that's prehistoric plant
material to have these trace minerals in
it we have a books let's play doctor
which has 400 nutritional formulas for
dealing with diseases and they can get
ahold of if I may can I give out sugar
numbers
go ahead one eight hundred seven five
five four six five six and they can be
hoe sale buyers of these things and save
themselves thirty percent off the market
price and certainly we love
to help you and help your viewers
appreciate okay Jeff thank you